[Music]
at what point for bart and joe here
at what point did you guys start
realizing you need to turn your life
around
uh and this is i'm talking about like
the
the early days of like your criminal uh
brush your body with the criminal life i
would have to say
it probably was a back and forth
discussion for six years
for six years wow oh wow i threw that
number out who's the conversation with
yourself myself
like okay the moment that somebody got
shot in front of my friend's house
i said is this the smartest thing to do
right now
and then so um we decided that we can
still
is we you and yourself are you in friend
me myself and i and couple of my friends
that i manipulated into leaving
um so we convinced manipulate is the
wrong word
but i helped i rescued their life so
it's not a bad word it's not a bad thing
to do
right so then um when someone
got shot in front of my friend's house
[ __ ] got real and i started unraveling
like this whole you know fake loyalty
and all that stuff and then i was like
why am i like dedicating my life to this
[ __ ]
we can do all the same things make money
party have fun
without this name that we're holding and
without the enemies we can start fresh
and all that
so it's still half foot in half food out
you know like you're doing stupid things
you're still
doing like you're just not going to
school being a part of society you're
still
you know being an idiot but like you
just have no
name around it like there's no crew name
around it were you afraid to leave
yeah i think that's why i played it very
carefully because if i was the only one
to leave then obviously
they you know the whole group can turn
on me but then if i can get into the
ears of people one by one and then we
all meet up and leave at the same time
then they can't do anything
yeah so that's kind of where we we got
to
going to yeah i see what about you for
me
i think uh it started when i was six
and i was like i'm a very bad boy don't
be a bad boy anymore and i just keep
doing more and more bad boy [ __ ]
at six yes six we were having this i
knew
i was mischievous i don't know why i
couldn't control my urges
and i just kept doing more and more [ __ ]
and i kept bleeding and then finally
like i think when i was maybe like 18 or
19.
oh [ __ ] this is longer than six years
ago this is a long
yeah i i thought that
i'm not doing bad things it's just some
people get caught and others don't
because like i don't know like i don't
i just started seeing the hypocrisy so
i'm like okay
why is it that governments can kill
people with a badge
but i can't because they're just a group
says you can
it doesn't mean that they're doing it
for right like soldiers and [ __ ] right
like in elementary you hear about world
war
one and two and you just hear about like
soldiers going into war and killing
so i'm like how come they can kill but i
can't mine wasn't that you wanted to
you wanted you wanted that freedom no i
didn't want to kill
i just so so when you're a kid the
system is [ __ ] you're you're
you're you're taught the rules don't
apply to so i grew a christian right
and then in the ten commandments it's
thou shalt not kill that's one of the
things right
but these heroes these soldiers
they kill all the time but they're not
sinful
and i'm like why like the religion
didn't say that's okay
yeah but they're christian and then but
the government says it's okay that's why
it's okay
and then i would think about it and i'm
all like that's weird just because some
people say it's okay
then it's okay not because god said it's
okay and then my mind was just kind of
like
well what these people aren't higher
than
god so why should i listen to them and
then i saw the school system and they're
like you need a job
so why do i need a job so you could work
and i'm like
why do i need to work right you're just
directed to go
go
yes and i got my ass beat for asking
those questions so i started to stop
trusting my parents
and i think that route got my mind to go
more attracted to like
delinquent people or back yeah because
now you're taking it into your own hands
yeah because i don't trust adults
authority or people
and i think i gravitated toward that
because it's more fun oh
absolutely because it's more fun to
party smoke weed and then
be against society and do all these
things and you're around people that are
more like
not just gang life but like just if
you're around a bunch of skaters or
anybody that's anti
society right you just kind of you're
kind of like on the bad side or like you
rather just do drugs and play
and you don't want to be a part of this
like let's be good citizens and work and
whatever
i think that um for me i was like what's
the point like what's the point of
working in the system doing all this
stuff that you're supposed to do
and then it just felt like this weird
slavery
and then so from elementary school i was
just like this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
fake man i hate the fakeness true i mean
you're not wrong for thinking that way
because
that's a pretty uh you know i think
honest
question to ask at some point in
everyone's life why am i stuck in the
system right
no one gave me an answer that made me
feel like that was
that was a good answer for me to follow
it always felt like
[ __ ] yeah i didn't arrive at the
gang life
that way mine was like in first grade
i just thought it'd be funny every time
the teacher started writing on the
chalkboard if i make
fart sounds and then i just couldn't
stop myself from doing it so i get in
trouble
go to the principal's office and then i
realize there's other kids that are
there
for fighting and then so i'm like i
guess we're like in the same group and
then we kind of understand each other
and so we're here for different purposes
and then it's just eventually like oh
these guys are way more accepting than
the other kids because that's what i
like too
because some kids are like they look at
me as if i'm interrupting the class
right so there's a sense of belonging i
think bad kids are way
more accepting yeah or i felt way more
accepted way more you're misfits
then yeah then like the good kids the
good kids like their parents told them
not to hang with me i felt like
wrong or weird and then i mean i'm not
that's not even gang life yet that's
just feeling not
a part of society right no one
understands you yeah and then eventually
you get into gang life because you're
attracted to that
and then you keep pushing the boundaries
of bad [ __ ] like let's say you're out
for days because you just don't want to
go home right
and then i think runaways and kids that
are kind of like that you're attracted
to gain life because they start taking
care of you
like when you're a part of that group if
someone makes money like they
did something sold drugs broke into a
home or whatever right
technically like what happens well in my
experience is they'll
they'll feed you they'll like you're
just out for three days and they'll be
like hey let's go grab some burgers or
whatever
and then you have a place to stay
there's like a crash pad there's like
whatever and it's nice
it's like lord of the flies it's like uh
it's like a sleepover every single day
and you can party do whatever you want
and then you gotta maintain it somehow
so you got to make money
right and then that's kind of where it
goes you just go into crazy [ __ ]
yeah i see i see yeah so this article i
have here
is about a former drug dealer and he
served 16 years
in prison but guess where he's at now
harvard prison again uh
homeboy not too far off with the harvard
thing and not
wrong for saying prison he now has a phd
in criminology he's a professor
teaching students uh uh working with
students in prisons so like
underage kids uh in like the president
so you guys are yeah professor in prison
professor
in prison after serving 16 years in
prison he went back prisoners
full disclosure though i'll tell you
guys something [ __ ] crazy right
okay let me think how can i format this
all right so
i stay in contact with my old friends
if you get my drift right and and and
the last draw
for me to hanging out with this group
was uh during college
when i was kind of not sure if i want to
um
uh uh uh be fully legit because i still
felt like these are my friends and i
want i don't want to leave them right
so one day they go let's go let's go to
the club we go we go to hollywood
uh as soon as we get into the club they
stab
some dudes so we gotta run away we go to
a we go
to a cafe because you know when people
drink they just want to go
hang out and whatever and the girls of
the group
didn't like some other girls that were
sitting in the table
and in the middle of the restaurant all
these girls started pulling each other's
hair
fighting and yelling it was some crazy
ass tribal [ __ ] man and i was like what
the [ __ ]
and so we leave we gotta go to another
place to eat right
so we go cause i still didn't get my
[ __ ] plate
and we go to another cafe we park in the
parking lot and as soon as we walk out
a car drives up and starts shooting at
us i [ __ ] drop to the ground my
friends want to be like
i don't give a [ __ ] bullets don't
[ __ ] hit me they keep walking like
nothing right
yeah i'm on the floor like a scary
little [ __ ] they're just standing there
like it's just bullets
and i'm like you [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] right oh my god
and i was like are we leaving i was like
are we leaving and they're like
nah we're just gonna [ __ ] eat and
then so
i see cops come down they pull over that
car that just shot because it was just a
cop around the corner right
we're eating dinner with watching 10
[ __ ] cops just grabbing up that car
that shot at us
apparently they mistaken this group for
another group that was just at the cafe
and i'm just like man what happens all
the time yeah is this
really the [ __ ] that i want i'm going
into college now and i'm learning about
the normal world and i'm like
it's just less anxiety inducing right
so after that point i haven't seen this
dude and then um
he went to jail for a little bit so we
kind of lost
you know track of each other he and he
dm's me like six years ago we keep
chatting right and i know this guy since
like
over 20 years now so like he's my
childhood friend
so i feel close to him and it and we're
cool and then
um just just to catch up we decided to
get some burgers the other day
so we're eating and i have this like
weird [ __ ] feeling right
and i'm getting like scared and like my
chest is all like tensing up and i'm
just listening to this guy talk
and i'm like did you eat burgers with
them with the pigtails and stuff
sticking out that would be funny right
no like i'm i'm listening to everything
that he's been through like we literally
went this way right so he
he continued that certain life like he's
doing well but he's always watching over
his shoulder and all this stuff and like
um some of our other childhood friends
that they were
that belong like they're it's it's lit
it's literally like a mafia saga like
they
[ __ ] him over really bad um i have
another i have an even more
closer childhood friend where our
parents knew each other right and he
told me some things about him and
and he just completely disappeared and i
can't find him
and like yeah so our family friends are
just not
they knew that this guy went missing
right but i was like where the [ __ ] did
he go and i heard what happened
there's just a lot of [ __ ] that went
down and i was just sitting there and my
heart was racing
and i'm all like [ __ ] dude i think that
uh
i used to live in fear every [ __ ] day
then i didn't realize it
so then weren't you normal for you yeah
and when you when you leave that
situation and you look back
and you just hear about the stories it's
kind of like
holy [ __ ] i i was there and i could have
been continuously there for you
and now i'm like what are you doing now
man like are you trying to get the hell
out of this and he's like so
what he's doing is so addicting because
the money is amazingly well
but it's so dangerous right but he
doesn't know anything else
and so he and and for him he's like it's
like being on welfare he's like
imagine he's like you don't have to do
any [ __ ] work
right you're just kind of sitting around
and he's like and you're collecting
like a hundred thousand dollars here and
there and he's like
but you have to work with the same
people to to get this
and he's like i know that there's a
different thing for me to do
but he's like i'm so
uh what do you call it like comfortable
he's like i can't get out of it
and i'm just like well what the [ __ ]
dude like i don't know man
and then for me i was just like just
listening to it
brought me back into a place of this
weird
uh experience of like i'm living through
it too
yeah it was it was just a weird
experience i think i was telling bart
about this too
how like there's some more details about
it that are like really [ __ ] scary
but after that i was like all right i'll
probably be another 20 years since i
till i see you bro
yeah because it links your right to that
emotion i get that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like you're triggered dude he triggered
you basically you were triggered yeah i
guess that's what it was
man triggered my ptsd you were triggered
by literally getting [ __ ] almost shot
at
yeah i can remembering that that's wild
yeah
but yeah in short this article here
um is about the guy named steven pabio
clementowski acapio uh
this is what he looks like he is i think
he's an immigrant
uh from he's a professor at college now
africa
yeah he's he's a university college
professor in london now
and he's awesome he works with kids in
the prison system
and uh yeah so his story was basically
dealing drugs
uh when his father died so he wasn't
growing up in the best of
neighborhoods father dies he turns to
drug dealing gets caught 16 years in
prison
but while in prison though he had an
epiphany
and realized um in his words he didn't
see the world as a meritocracy
and instead he felt like the world was
more about whatever you can just get
your hands on
a lot of people see it that way exactly
and so for him he realized
and there was there's a library in the
prison so he was just like i'm gonna
start reading books and he started
educating himself
and he and he would enroll in the open
university in the uk and i guess
while in prison he was able to enroll
into this university and that's where he
started educating and uh
and like one of the images he would
paint in his interview was uh he would
spend nights uh sitting on the toilet
[ __ ] while reading books with his
cellmate just sleeping right next to him
and that was like like i had to add the
shitty
yeah i don't know why but that's quite
the visual though i mean that's how
dedicated this guy was
turned his life around and i just
thought that was uh that's a really
really
awesome beautiful story to share and
it's like you don't you don't hear these
awesome stories every day we hear about
all the negativity in the world so
just wanted to share this one with you
guys yeah yeah your story
pretty [ __ ] nuts yeah like getting
out of the system and like
yeah yeah it's like a different it's a
different life but it's hard to man
absolutely he found purpose that's
that's what a lot of people don't find
yeah and that's like if you can find
purpose like he wanted to help other
people
get out of the system right because he
works with kids that have his similar
upbringing
yeah he relates directly to discovered
something he's like i want to help you
with something that i wish i would have
known
right right right
[Music]
[Music]
you